hello grammarians today I want to talk
about one of the absolute thorniest
issues in usage of English and it's the
difference between there there and there
and if you can't tell the difference
from the way I'm saying it that's
because it's really confusing and evil
and that is why I'm here is to help you
make a distinction between these three
sound-alike words now first of all we
have their th e re which we're going to
use orange for is an adverb and an
adjective and it's used to signify where
something is so the way to remember that
this one is all about location it was
just to take the T and replace it with
the W the question is where the answer
is there so have you been to Greece yes
I went there I'm not gonna have you seen
my dog yes there's my dog so you asked
the question where did you go I went
there where is my dog there is my dog
and technically this is an adverb you'll
use here there is modifying went and
here is an adjective use because there
is modifying dog the second member of
this confusing trio is their th e IR
which is a possessive determiner let's
just call that a possessive so this is
when something belongs to Ave and it's
an adjective so let's just call this a
possessive adjective for some--for of a
su and Freda ate their icecream cones so
th e ir the possessive
answers the question who does that
belong to so rounding out our trio the
last member of the they're there they're
writers of the Apocalypse is th ey
apostrophe re which is a contraction of
they are so anywhere you would want to
say they are you can smoosh that
together and say there so hey kid are
your parents home no they're not home
right now
can I take a message so you
can see in this sentence they're not
home right now can I take a message
there th ey apostrophe re is replacing
they are both of these things would work
equally well in the sense that both
grammatical ones just shorter and as we
know English as with most languages
likes to take the easy route finding the
shortest possible or most efficient
option if you prefer so as a writer and
speaker of English you're going to come
across this situation a lot which one of
these things do you use and so when you
come across this funny little issue do I
use there there or there you have to ask
yourself a series of questions question
number one does it answer the question
where is it if so use th e re if the use
answers the question who does it belong
to then use th e IR if what you're
trying to say is a contraction of they
are then what you're looking for is th
ey apostrophe re I know it's confusing
but you can learn anything Dave it out